best-selling author Michael Lewis has
sold more than 9 million copies of his
books in the United States alone three
of his novels were turned into feature
films The Blind Side
Moneyball and the big short his latest
book is the undoing project that follows
the collaboration between two Israeli
psychologists their research into
decision-making challenge beliefs about
human nature
Lewis is also exploring government
issues in his new Vanity Fair article
made in the USDA
Michael Lewis joins us at the table
welcome back pleasure to be here so this
is really interesting and I know it's a
series of articles but why did you
choose to write about the USDA would you
find well it's you have to understand
the series of articles understand why so
I the Obama the Obama administration
went to great lengths to prepare for the
transition hundreds of people spent
better part of a year building briefing
books have to explain to whoever came in
what you did in the Department of
Agriculture or Department of Energy and
in many cases the Trump administration
just didn't show up the briefings never
happened so I went I was curious what
the consequences of that were ignorant
of the of this dysfunctional handover of
the government and so I went got the
briefings I mean well that's what I'm
doing so you sit in the meeting so I
would go and find the people who were
meant to give have given these briefings
and I pick I'd call and they say sure
they'd say sure come come talking they
never got a chance and so I did that a
couple of months ago with the Department
of Energy and and I picked the
Department of Agriculture oddly because
I wanted to just test the proposition
pick some obscure place that nobody is
thinking about and is there any interest
there and so what did you find out bunch
of things one the stakes are enormous
even in the Department of Agriculture if
like the Department of Energy it's miss
named it shouldn't be called the
department agriculture maybe the
Department of food but but a huge part
of his budget goes to feeding people who
can't afford food all people kids poor
people and the the risk of mismanaging
the programs is the risk to the weak in
the society but you me know Michael when
you say didn't show up you said it's
open for business and literally nobody
comes and when they do come they're not
qualify so so I entered
dozens of people inside the Department
of Agriculture who were who would have
been involved one way or another with
this transition they had set up a floor
in the building with workstations and
briefing books for the day preparing for
the day after the election because
that's typically what happens is teams
rush in the day after the election and
try to get up to speed before the
inauguration and not only did not a team
show up nobody showed up for weeks and
eventually people trickle in like six
weeks later one person shows up and the
briefings that happen are the sense that
the people who gave the briefings got
was because they happen so they were so
brief and shallow was they were doing it
just to be able to say they did you said
they had no interest in knowledge when
they did come that's that was the
repression of the people who were giving
the briefings yeah pushback from the
USDA
it says the reporting is false adding
that the transition team was frequently
engaged and that appointees were
appropriately screen to place them in
positions aligned with their abilities
and experience so this is a charming
response in many ways because at least
they're now acknowledging they should
have done it and they're embarrassed
they didn't do it
I thought the response was going to be
oh we didn't need to know any of that
but they you could talk to the people as
I did you can interview all the people
who were meant to be delivering these
briefings okay nobody showed up I mean
there were parking spaces that were left
empty they were desks that rent being at
least these the the Trent look the
federal government is already kind of a
goofy operation you've got two million
employees doing things that we just take
for granted and they're run by this
group of four thousand political people
who come in sometimes they don't know
anything when they come in so they have
to get up to speed very quickly and so
there's already kind of a dysfunction
bit baked into the process you really
add to this function when the people
coming in don't know or seem to care
they've course-corrected well I didn't
really course-correct because what they
most many of the positions are still not
filled the only as of that when I wrote
the thing the only the secretary had
been put in and none of the under the
things a beneath the secretary had been
confirmed by said and they did they
dumped a bunch of people in the day on
the day of the inauguration and they
sent a bunch of people in
the resumes of those people Politico got
their hands on it and the degree that
lack of qualifications was just
astonishing one quick question about the
book was released in paperback the
undoing project in essence it is a
beautiful friendship between two people
it's a love story it's a love story it's
a love story it's a love story and it's
a funny love story because there's two
people who set out to study the way the
mind works when it's just calmly trying
to make judgments and decisions get
screwed up and their relationship is so
emotional it's a it's it's a it is this
it's an intellectual love story and the
children are ideas I say let's talk
baseball because you wrote Moneyball of
course about the Oakland A's do you see
any kind of correlation or relationship
between the Dodgers and the Houston
Astros
they are both they're both children of
Billy Beane and the Oakland A's you know
well foreign xiety who runs them as a
general manager of the Dodgers actually
was hired into baseball by Billy Beane
who had no experience playing or
managing or anything like that he was a
graduate student I think in economics
and so it's there and the fellow who
runs the the Astros Jeff Alou now again
an outsider management consultant there
are both teams represent the
intellectualization of the sport and so
what you saw going on in the field with
people playing but you saw behind it
where gear is grinding that were
unbelievably complicated would this be
true but the Cubs who won the World
Series last year yes same thing same
thing Theo Epstein who ran the Cubs so
this these these teams are being run if
you you know if you if you showed
someone from 20 years ago those games
the World Series they'd be puzzled by a
lot of it I mean the way the players
were positioned on the field who was
playing where and it's kind of funny is
that when when Moneyball came out one of
the raps against was it I was going to
make the game dull it's going to become
science on the field and this world
series was anything but dull I mean what
you've got was an added layer of
interest because there's this
intellectual life behind it yeah Michael
Michael great to have you here as always
the undoing project wiser to be here
available in paperback